you might want to check up on your crazy  conservative father tonight because  tucker said some stuff  yes it appears carlson thinks the  government will lace our water supply  with antidepressants  to pacify americans and it's come and he  says  i'm not drinking tap water anymore  okay no i doubt that they would actually  do that  although  you never know what the government will  do i doubt that they would actually do  that but i wouldn't be surprised if the  amount of antidepressants that people  are taking is making its way into the  water supply anyway i'm pretty sure  birth control is i think there are  studies on that so  i wouldn't be surprised